就好了，
陈妈你好，
能听到你遇到啥事吗？
我就不可能不是感情上问题啊，
就是偏工作一点，
呃，
我老公他是前两个月公司倒闭了，
然后现在就是在家里待了两三个月嘛，
前段时间是出去玩，
然后最近找工作有一点点，
就是说价格往下了，
价格往下呢，
我就是觉得我们家里条件其实还可以，
然后我的性趣还行，
我是觉得如果低于15K的话，
还不如在家里带带孩子啊，
因为我们做金融嘛，
他自己的表达能力啊，
他的学业背景做特别好，
我觉得他如果可以就是从媒媒体做一做，
自己拍拍视频，
哪怕没有什么粉丝，
就是说也可以让他的这个，
呃，
演讲或者是表达能力也可以继续保持，
没让他的这个经济神也比较好，
他也蛮顾家的，
各个方面，
我就觉得我现在有点矛盾，
反正是支持他去找工作，
哪怕是1万多，
还是说支持他在家里管管孩子，
然后我平时也管注是两个人一起还子在顺便做一下这个自媒体，
我现在有点不确定，
我觉得可能如果一个人就是远离社交或者职场酒的话，
他他因为他是一个心态非常好的人，
作息也都很规律，
我最近感觉到。
可能经济神上有一点略弱，
我觉得是不是要去，
哪怕是工工资少一点，
嗯，
就是保持一个人的状态是不是比较重要一点，
然后我又有点纠结，
就是如果说我们俩都工作的话，
可能是必要老人过来帮帮忙接送孩子啊之类的，
我又不想家里增加一些这部分的矛盾嘛，
因为平时也有工作，
然后带孩子本来也也比较累，
回来的时候就想躺平，
那这样子的话，
老人在总感觉会有一点。
不自在，
所以现在有一点小纠结，
还是尊重他，
就是他的人生课题，
就是他是想在外面找一个工资低一点的工作，
保持一样一个状态，
还是他想在孩子家里面带孩子，
他挺想在家里的，
他也比较尊重我们，
我呢平时给他压力不大的，
就是我自己一个人的条件也完全可以覆覆盖的了，
家里的这个开支也好，
或者说贷款也好，
但是可能他自己的父母因为也都是告知嘛，
不大能接受的了，
马上要过年了，
可能压力也蛮大的，
他的父母能不能接受是他父母的课题，
你不要掺和进去，
你不要试图说我帮着我老公去说服他的父母来接受这个事儿，
No,
你的爹妈你自己管，
你自己去说服，
你自己去面对，
我可不管，
我就扮演好一个，
哎呀，
我支持我老公，
我老公选什么样的对吧，
选什么样的状态的话，
我都能支持，
你就扮演好这个角色就OK了，
而且在他如如果是刚刚失业，
刚刚在家带孩子这段过程当中的话，
尽可能的多在乎一下他的自尊，
觉得老公辛苦啦对吧，
回到家的时候说老公辛苦啦，
就这那个带孩子很累的吧，
嗯，
怎么怎么地的啊，
如果带孩子带的好的话，
你就多在乎。
一下，
因为人就是这样子的，
一个人可能一辈子就这么几次低谷，
就像我们女人怀孕生孩子这个过程当中，
老公如果对我特别好的话，
我这辈子都念着她的恩情，
念着她的好，
同样的道理，
她如果失业这段时间，
如果你甩脸色了来看他，
你鼻子不是鼻子，
脸不是脸了，
他可能这辈子就记得当初我失业的时候，
你多么的对我冷漠，
对是想他对自己非非常有信心，
他说你看着吧，
你老公这得不会这样的，
他心态相当好的，
就我觉得他应该最近是上学，
人生低谷，
但是就是说按照他自己的想法，
他说因为怎么说，
做金融就是有一对各方面信息也比较敏感嘛，
就是外盘啊，
各方面，
他这个获取信息能力其实很强，
他说他自己哪怕不去工作，
在二级上也能挣到钱，
但是我觉得这个已经不稳定了，
但是非就是您这样讲的话，
就还是根据他自己的意思，
因为我自己这边完全可以覆盖负担的了的话，
就没有必要管他那么多了，
对不对，
是的，
没错，
那有的时候有点看不下去，
就觉得怎么说呢，
他嗯日常也得开销，
他自己就是覆盖覆盖不了自己的话，
他有点想出去贷款，
有一小部分负债吧，
那我。
就就就觉得总归想要把负债，
哪怕房贷啊这些就是硬性的，
如果说自己消费啊，
有一些负债的话，
我可能稍微比较传统一点，
我觉得可能就尽快给他还掉，
他觉得有一点点负债在身上的话，
也没有任何关系，
就是自产负债表总归有资产有负债也是健康的，
我就觉得男也想改变一个人也也也不容易，
你就还是听他的，
哪怕他有负债也都是他自己的，
就让他自己弄是吧，
他是爸妈都是体制内退休的是吧，
对的，
然后他还是独子是吧？
对，
所以他是有一定的人生容错率的，
是的，
他他自己也说了，
别那么担心，
其实上面还有老的兜着他，
我说你不能犒劳的呀，
这事儿他自己自洽就行，
看他自下有，
有的时候是你得这么想问题，
只要他自己自洽，
他不去干那种捅大窟窿的事儿，
他不去干那种什么抵押房产，
借几十万上百万，
然后去投资搞项目的事，
那都还在可控的范围之内，
因为他的人生确实是有容错率的，
他父母都有退休工资，
他又是独职是吧，
那钱都是他的父母，
那些财产都是他的，
他有一定的容错率，
他一定是让他自信啊，
他就怕说你这头如果给到他。
一定的心理压力了，
如果让他觉得他必须很快的要挣到这些钱了，
怕就怕他走歪门邪道了，
到时候他就走风险特别高的，
那些金融圈的事儿你也都知道啊，
怕就怕这个行那那这样子也就没什么问题了，
就是那算了，
你就让他在家待着，
他也闲不住，
我告诉你在家带孩子也是一件很痛苦的事情，
他在家待最多待一年，
他都得出去找工作，
所以我想得我要不要多分他一点，
就是带孩子的这一部分，
因为我觉得他现在挺舒适的，
因为我自己像也不是说完全不管嘛，
也带的他觉得现在挺舒服，
你的目的不是为了逼他出去工作，
你的目的是让他就是人生有一个缓冲，
带你的目的就是我觉得我老公各方面都还行，
也没有什么不良嗜好，
对孩子也还挺好的，
我跟我这个老公想好好过，
但是他确实现在是失业了这样一个状态，
我的目的不是说我要现在就是让他感受到在家里面带孩子不幸福，
他赶紧出去找工作了吧，
不是我的的就是心理上给他一个缓冲态，
不管是一年也好，
两年也好，
让他自己缓冲一下行，
好的，
那我就多一个担心，
我担心他回头状态不好，
如果在家待的时间久了，
万一脱节了，
或者是说就是精气神更好，
你如果不逼他，
他不会状态不好。
哦，
对，
现在就是这样，
那如果你们非得让我去工作，
那我去去也没事，
去也没问题，
就是这意思，
如果其就你们对我没啥要求，
能让我自己选的话，
我就想给他在家里，
那就让他待在家里带带孩子吧，
也挺好，
孩子有这样一个长期的爸爸在陪伴在身边，
这个过程也挺好，
对孩子，
孩子就算挺幸福的，
毕竟爷爷奶奶还有退休工资了，
还有一定的兜底，
跟奶奶还支持呢，
就近爷爷奶奶看不下去，
前两天我婆婆给我打电话说你你你别太惯着他，
你还得让她出去工作，
然后我我就我觉得就是见人说人话，
见鬼说鬼话呗，
婆婆打的时候你也打哈哈呗，
好的妈，
我抽空我会跟他说的，
但实际上在现实生活当中的话，
你就观察你老公呗，
她自己能自洽，
她不捅窟窿的话，
家里也没有太大的经济负担的话，
先这样陪伴孩子也挺好，
好的你谢谢，
没事，
拜拜拜。
我觉得我自己有的时候都需要那种缓冲状态，
有的时候说哎呀明天要停电了，
我说哎呀明天不用上班了，
缓冲一下挺高兴，
哎呀，
对吧，
最近这段时间什么孩子又不听话了，
我要专心陪一下孩子了，
哎呀，
又不用上班了，
心里又可美了，
就是这种感觉，
每个人可能都会需要一种缓冲期了，
人生的缓冲期谁都需要。
所以我也能理解这份工作，
我公司黄了，
正好有这么个一段时间啊，
半年啊，
一年啊，
有个缓冲期，
对整个人生来说是很美好的这样一个缓冲期。